Одне крісло - для молодшої доньки.
- Дитина не вилітає вперед, дві системи кріплення.
Друге - бустер - для старшого сина.
- Це автокрісло трохи піднімає дитину,
і зручно пристібати його звичайним ременем.
Воно під горло там не заходить.
Киянка Марія - мати двох дітей, чекає на третю
і останні 6 років возить дітей лише в автокріслах.
Її чоловік - німець. У родині переконані,
що по-іншому - просто недопустимо.
- Взагалі не уявляю, як можна не користуватися автокріслом,
бо дуже небезпечно на дорогах.
Пригадую, як у дитинстві ми їздили в "жигулях" чи то у "волгах" батьків
і билися там головою при крутих поворотах.
Я вважаю, що не треба з дітьми такого робити.
Марія зізнається, що часто бачить, коли діти сидять
на передньому сидінні або просто в батьків на руках
без пасків безпеки. Жінка відверто радіє тому, що
нарешті таких водіїв штрафуватимуть.
Верховна Рада нещодавно ухвалила закон, який
передбачає адміністративну відповідальність за неналежне перевезення дітей.
Згідно з законом, дітей до 12 років або тих,
чий зріст нижчий, ніж 145 см, перевозити можна
лише в автокріслах. За порушення водій має
сплатити штраф у розмірі 510 гривень. За повторне
порушення - 850 гривень штрафу. Більшість
батьків-водіїв, із якими поспілкувалася DW,
ставляться до нових штрафів із розумінням.
- Безпека - це найголовніше. Я двома руками "за".
У нас вже дорослі діти, але якби була маленька дитина,
то користувався б лише кріслом.
- Я рада, що такий закон вступив у силу. Може, ті,
хто нехтував безпекою дітей, тепер не буде так вчиняти.
Якщо не з любові до дітей, то хоча б за законом.
Проте більшість автомобілів на українських трасах
усе ще їздять з дітьми без крісел. За оцінками,
свідомих автовласників - лише від 12 до 20%.
Переважно йдеться про дітей лише до 5-6 років.
Для доросліших спеціальні сидіння майже не купують.
Тепер після запровадження штрафів продавці
фіксують підвищений попит на автокрісла для дітей.
- Попит збільшився, на наступний день ми продали
майже всі автокрісла, які були в нашому відділі,
а це десь 10. Після цього замовляли нові
і в наступні 3-4 дні їх теж розкуповували.
Хто поки не готовий до негайного втілення нових
правил перевезень, це таксисти. Дехто і раніше
не брав пасажирів з дітьми, бо не має автокрісел.
- Ми не беремо дітей. Дітей до 12 років ми не маємо права
навіть із батьками брати, якщо у нас немає крісел.
Інші таксисти не на камеру зізналися, що
погоджуються перевозити дітей без автокрісел і
вважають питання їхньої безпеки відповідальністю батьків.
А купувати крісла не хочуть, бо це дорого.
Таксисти вважають, що взагалі треба звільнити їх
від відповідальності за відсутність дитячих автокрісел
і застосовувати новий закон лише для автомобілів приватного користування.
Перевізники кажуть, що інакше це не реалістично,
бо для дітей різного віку потрібні різні крісла.
Усе це займатиме багато місця в багажнику.
- Замовлень на перевезення дітей - 1-2%
від загальної кількості замовлень. 20-30% - це
перевезення пасажирів з валізами - на вокзал, в аеропорт.
Якщо дотримуватися правил, то треба возити в багажнику крісла.
Мені буде простіше відмовити пасажирам з дітьми.
Ярослав саме придивляється до автокрісел, планує придбати бустер.
Загалом він підтримує нові правила. Але каже, що
закон треба ще доопрацювати з огляду на скарги таксистів.
- Ось іде взимку мати з дитиною і її  відмовляються підвезти,
тому що стоїть патруль
і, звісно, це порушення і в людини немає цього крісла.
Усі підстави будуть, щоб його оштрафувати.
Закон і мораль завжди йдуть поруч, але це
дуже часто відрізняється.
Деякі компанії-перевізники вже почали активно
освоювати ринок "дитячих перевезень".  Подорожі коштують дорожче,
але можливі за попереднім замовленням.
Марія Каель переконана, що закон повинен запрацювати негайно,
адже батьки можуть брати в таксі чи в машину
до друзів свої автокрісла. Це вкрай важливо, аби
убезпечити дітей і не поповнювати жахливу статистику ДТП.
За даними Нацполіції, в Україні від початку року в ДТП
загинули 148 дітей, більше трьох тисяч травмовані.
Переважна більшість з них не мали автокрісел.